thank you cheri are you wondering what
to eat for dinner tonight like myself
all right how about the most famous
italian recipe
spaghetto al pomodoro how did i say that
we'll ask the chef coming up
all right which is made with the very
simple ingredients tastes delicious
and is really simple to make so this
afternoon executive chef matthew chacho
joins us from italy las vegas at park
mgm to share a few secrets
to making the perfect spaghetti dish
chef how did i say that did i butcher it
or
no pun intended
testing and perfecting this recipe
absolutely all these ingredients are
sourced from italy
they're sourced from all over the
country you know it's one of those
we found the best of all the ingredients
we could and we put them together
and it was wow this is one incredible
dish that everybody's going to love on
this
and when you think italian food you
think you forget the pomodoro
okay so let's get into it i have a setup
right here i'm ready this is uh the most
i've done in the kitchen all week
all right let's get into it so right
here i have my pasta my pasta's been
cooking in heavily salted water for
about 12 minutes
okay you want that pasta water to taste
almost like the soup so when you taste
it you almost want to spit it out
oh that's a nice secret i hope
everyone's taking notes
my pasta's been cooking it's ready to go
right here so what i'm going to do right
now
is straight from the pan sorry straight
from the pasta water
with a little bit of water into my pan
oh
okay so i'm gonna pour the i'm gonna
pour the sauce onto the actual noodles
here
got a little different setup
oh my gosh this is amazing okay and i
hear the ingredients are the star
of this dish and it's super simple
what kind of tomatoes do you need what
kind of tomatoes
the tomatoes you need for this dish
they're available here at italy with us
these are kosikome tomatoes
they're sweet they're whole they're
unpeeled there's no preservatives in
them there's no added anything
i love it so simple this is so easy for
me and everyone else watching i hope you
guys are taking notes but you can get
recipes
online right at just eataly.com
absolutely.com or in person
that is awesome thank you so much we're
gonna feast in here we appreciate you
chef
all right we'll be right back from las
vegas